hey you're very um i feel like in the
last couple of years you've been very
selective
about who you do records with like i
feel like a lot of people would be in
your position and we'd hear them on a
lot more other artists project but i
feel like with you
um
like when you hop on a track it's very
like few and far between
42 doug record the nle chopper record
um
what is it like that has to click for
you to like actually get on some [ __ ]
because i'm sure if you wanted to you
could be on everyone's [ __ ] album you
know what i'm saying
is it i just feel like
just my personality i'm selected with my
women i'm selected with even music
selected wit the clothes i put on i'm
selected with the people i hang around
is just more so lifestyle
so you know when it comes to business
sometimes people may think it's a little
crazy for me to turn down a lot of [ __ ]
but i just gotta [ __ ] with it too
and you got you have to like really [ __ ]
with the person or be at least be a fan
of what they're doing exactly yeah more
so you know because a lot of times you
know
i just don't i don't want nobody singing
along to a song that i'm on and i don't
really like the song that's just the
simplicity of it do you ever look back
at some of the old [ __ ] you you did
before maybe like you were in the
position you're in now and like be like
damn
because you know i feel like most
artists when you're on that independent
grind yeah you might pull up in a city
you might get a bag for a feature you
might get a bag for a hook you know what
i'm saying like
i feel like we all haven't been there
before but everybody has for sure just
me being who i am at this point i feel
like i just stand more firm on what i
believe
and i just do what i want to do at this
point whatever happened to
the drake song i know there was at least
one
yeah
like why did we never i remember you
were telling me and head about them i
think we're at real street fest and and
we were talking about it but like
whatever happened to the drake [ __ ]
dropping like why did that never come
out i don't really know honestly
fair enough i'm not sure you have a lot
of songs that don't come out but
obviously you know that's yeah i mean
like bro me i don't bank on doing no
song with nobody bro you talking to a
[ __ ] i went diamond by myself